you heard it here first folks nvidia is
launching yet another 30 series gpu that
nobody's going to be able to find in
stock but it's not all bad because for
the handful of gamers who do get their
hands on this thing at msrp it is going
to be one heck of a gameful christmas
because spoiler alert the 3060 ti is
hella fast
i'll tell you all about it but first
i'll tell you about our sponsor team
group team group's dark z alpha ddr4
memory is compatible with ryzen 5000 and
you can win a computer that uses this
ram at team group's christmas giveaway
at the link below
[Music]
scalpers aside i'd be lying if i said i
am not super excited about these cards
at 399 the msrp
the value they represent is substantial
for anyone with a pc who's looking for a
console alternative especially when you
consider that according to nvidia anyway
it's faster than an rtx 2080 super and
you know what
on paper anyway i think i believe them
it's got more than double the previous
gen rtx 2060 supers cuda cores and at
just a 25 watt increase in rated power
consumption in fact the core count is
only about 20 percent lower than the rtx
3070 with specs that are otherwise
pretty comparable same 8 gigs of gddr6
memory same bandwidth and just a few
less robs you'd expect that to translate
into roughly 20 lower overall
performance to put that theory to the
test we've gathered not only the rtx
3060 ti and rtx 2080 super but the next
steps up for both of these gpus and team
red's latest and greatest to see just
how far four benjamin's theoretically
will get you
[Music]
good thing we didn't pay for ours
because christmas would have been
completely ruined we've spoken with
nvidia and our card is almost certainly
defective but we're going to keep going
anyway since the performance numbers
look okay and we can't get another one
here in time we'll just have to skip
some of our tests for traditional gaming
shadow the tomb raider places the rtx
360 ti firmly behind the 3070 and the
2080 ti although worryingly for amd its
ray trace performance roughly matches
their
569 dollar rx 6800 and completely
embarrasses it in fully path traced
minecraft rtx where the differences
between the rtx cards are actually
slimmer than i would have expected
wolfenstein youngblood in traditional
rasterizing has our higher end cards
pulling away from the 3060 ti although
we weren't able to test ray tracing
performance here due to that problem
with our review sample microsoft great
equalizer or flight simulator makes
short work of the 360 ti relegating it
to console fps status unless you're
prepared to reduce your resolution or
your visual quality and finally cs go
has the 3060 ti nearly beating out the
2080 ti albeit with slightly worse frame
pacing if the 95th percentile minimums
are anything to go by so it looks pretty
great from a gaming standpoint as for
productivity the rtx 360 ti just
straight up drop kicks the last gen even
the 2080 ti with performance that is
surprisingly close to the 3070
especially with the optics renderer at
sub 20 seconds for the bmw test and the
spanking gets even more thorough as we
move on to v-ray and octane bench with
only the rtx off results for the latter
dipping below the rtx 2080 ti
spec vue perf finally has the 2080 super
trading blows with the 3060 ti with 3ds
max and maya pulling off wins for the
new card thanks to the extra cuda course
and solidworks seeing better performance
out of the previous gen thanks to its
higher clock speed physically the
founder's edition looks pretty much
exactly like the rtx 3070 just with like
a you know a pallet swap slight color
change and that's from the cooler right
down to the new 12 pin connector which
i find a little bit frustrating the
biggest reason for which is that both
the 3070 and 3060 ti are now using this
special snowflake connector that they
have no practical need for whatsoever i
mean it's not the end of the world the
adapter is still included in the box so
it's not like it's gonna affect your
ability to plug the card into your power
supply i just don't really know what the
point is
maybe nvidia hopes that if enough cards
have this connector traditional pci
express power cables will eventually
disappear so far nobody seems to be
taking the bait throughout our testing
core clocks though were extremely stable
pushing past 2 gigahertz under most
circumstances to overtake the rtx 3070s
clock speeds and this seems to be thanks
in large part to the fewer cuda cores
and of course the reused cooler which is
just as potent our 360 ti founders hit a
peak of just 71 degrees throughout our
test which implies that there's a lot of
thermal headroom that remains to be
exploited average and maximum fan speeds
were also roughly the same between these
two cards suggesting that unless there's
bad thermal compound the 360 ti must be
drawing a similar amount of power too
which it is sitting at or below 200
watts most of the time with momentary
spikes as high as about 230 watts the
360 ti is just a bit lower than the rtx
3070 and surprisingly pretty close to
the rtx 2080 super i mean ampere is well
known by now for sucking back that juice
but it's still surprising to see this
kind of power draw in a 60 class card
and i'm sure it's going to cause a
headache or two for at least some of you
who are trying to upgrade a pre-built pc
or who skimped on your power supply way
back in the day
again though
it's not like a crazy amount and it's
nothing that a single 8-pin connector
couldn't have handled
now before our conclusion i want to
address the elephant in the room
using the msrp to review a product like
this when we know that it's unlikely to
be available at that price probably
seems pretty disingenuous to some of you
and i can see why people get mad about
it but the truth is there is no
conspiracy where nvidia is paying the
press to misrepresent the pricing or
whatever we just don't really have a
better way to deal with this
when we review a product we can only
work with the information that we have
at the time i don't know how much crazy
people are gonna pay to scalpers on ebay
and i don't know how long these
shortages are gonna last but the thing
is this video is gonna be up forever
long after these cards drop back down to
earth-like prices
so my best bet then is to just review it
from inside the bubble of how the world
is supposed to work and then offer the
caveat that you might need to wait in
order to get the value that we're
talking about here so with that in mind
then the conclusion despite the power
consumption the 3060 ti at 399 is going
to occupy a very popular spot on shelves
for both mid-range gamers and budget
conscious professionals alike it's a
great looking product it's fast it's
affordable it's got a ton of killer
features thanks to its rt course and
tensor cores which unlock nvidia's gamer
oriented ai goodness like rtx voice and
automatic background removal but all of
that stuff together means that it's
going to sell out basically instantly
just like i did to our sponsor
thanks to asus for sponsoring today's
video asus has been providing pc
components for almost 30 years and
they've shipped out over half a billion
motherboards and they couldn't do it
without the big support from the diy
community as a show of thanks they're
throwing a big celebration this december
3rd and they're going to show you guys
just how easy it is to build a pc also
there will be giveaways and challenges
so make sure you don't miss out by
checking out the link below thanks for
watching guys if you want a little bit
more gpu in your life maybe go check out
our review of the rx 6800 series amd's
response to nvidia's ampere it really is
better than i expected